[Música]
prazer eu sou gabriel nascido e criado
no norte de minas a família pouco
estruturada onde eu fui criado pela
minha bisavó e com a ajuda de algumas
dias também ao longo da vida num filho
de mãe solteira
assim eu cresci com um bem pequeno
assistia muito televisão e sempre ligado
à tecnologia a tecnologia da época ter
televisão e lá eu ouvia desenhos
animados e conhecer o famoso e
transporte onde tinha o poder de sair de
um lugar e ir para o outro
aqueles desenhos e personagens faziam
aqui eu pensava será que eu vou
conseguir até treinava sem ninguém me vê
e às vezes com alguns amiguinhos 1 mas
não dava certo eu fui crescendo e
comecei a entender que o teletransporte
nada mais é do que sair de um lugar e ir
pra outro e o amor pela viagem começou
ali
aos 12 anos de idade eu mudei de escola
mudança de escola novos amigos uma nova
realidade
fiz amizades com todos sempre fui muito
comunicativo
só que eu não tinha uma condição
financeira e colunas colega tinha pra
poder sair me divertir e com o meu
lanche
existe um cinema coisas do tipo eu
conheci o empreendedorismo
empreendedorismo mas gabriel como assim
eu comecei a vender balas chicletes
pirulitos para meus colegas e aí foi
crescendo comecei a vender a escola
inteira
a escola e atrás de mim falou gabriel
não pode vender mas eu continuava
vendendo porque ele
eu tinha uma renda extra para poder sair
com meus amigos tinham dinheiro para
poder pegar um despertar o mototáxi
pegar o ônibus para poder encontrar com
ele em outros lugares e foi firme no
empreendedorismo num mas
empreendedorismo nem sabia o que era
descobrir há pouco tempo atrás o termo
empreender ea pergunta é
empreendida sua vida e prender não é só
abrir um negócio
empreender é cuidar de você mesmo é
fazer com que as coisas que você mais
deseja o futuro incrível que você quer
realizar aconteça empreendendo e aí eu
fui crescendo e fiz uma amizade muito
forte essa nova escola com vinícius hoje
tenho orgulho e chamar de irmão vinícius
ele viajava com a família dele
todas as férias no exterior mas eu era
novo não tinha noção mal tinha saído do
estado de minas gerais e vi aqui ele
falava um dia eu também vou viajar ele
foi minha fonte de inspiração para um
dia eu fazia a viagem da minha vida
chegando no terceiro ano do ensino médio
começou a ter uma pressão muito forte
dentro do meu coração porque ouvia meus
colegas estão decididos a que curso que
profissão seguir
falavam que era o curso da vida havia
professores falando que eu decidi que eu
decidisse naquele momento seria o que eu
ia seguir para o resto da minha vida pra
ter muita cautela na minha decisão mas
eu só queria viajar
aquele desejo de tábua do seu coração
mas ninguém entendia
falavam que eu estava louco e talvez eu
estava mas eu vendo aqueles colegas
estão decididos falando eu vou fazer eu
vou fazer direito por ser um advogado
eu vou fazer medicina no seu grande
médico eu vou fazer publicidade e tantos
outros cursos
e eu pensava eu não sei que curso eu
quero fazer e às vezes na vida a gente
chega em um ponto de decisão onde você
tem que decidir como diz anthony
robinson é nos momentos de decisão o seu
destino traçado e o que você decide dia
após dia é o que acontece no seu futuro
a influência direta o que você faz hoje
você vai colher amanhã tanto coisas
positivas e negativas e aí nesse
processo de decisão tão forte na minha
vida eu fui aprovado em várias
faculdades particulares e foi aprovada
na universidade federal engenharia e foi
a decisão mais difícil que eu pude fazer
a minha família chorou muito porque eu
decidi não cursar
a universidade federal eu escolhi a
viagem e pode parecer maluco mas eu
tinha somente 17 anos e eu escolhi a
viagem e falei com minha família eu
quero fazer uma viagem quer aprender um
novo idioma inglês quer fazer um
intercâmbio gabriel e possível nossas
condições meu filho a gente não sabe o
que é um passaporte mas eu sei o que é
um passaporte pesquisei na internet e
comecei a correr atrás dos meus sonhos
mas como eu não tinha tanta condição
minha família não tinha como me ajudar
mas quando você tem um sonho e você quer
realizar
tem que haver planejamento e eu comecei
a planejar a viagem da minha vida e fiz
um planejamento conseguir trabalhar em
uma loja de roupa masculina de dois
amigos e um empregado foi deixa
trabalhar vai abrir a loja eu fico de 10
da manhã às 10 da noite eu faço todo o
turno porque eu preciso eu preciso fazer
uma renda para realizar o meu sonho e
comecei a planejar a minha viagem em
cima daquela renda e eu ia conseguir
realizar em dois anos ea pressão mais
uma vez começou a bater meu coração num
porque eu via meus colegas sendo
aprovados e cursando cursos estão
decididos e eu querendo fazer uma viagem
todo mundo falava 'você tá louco gabriel
vai estudar mas eu fui week dois anos
para poder realizar o meu sonho dentro
da loja tem espírito empreendedor tomou
conta de mim lá dentro eu comecei a
perguntar a eles eu posso vender algo
que você não vende aqui eles me deram
total abertura comecei a fazer pulseiras
personalizadas e comecei a vender e fui
entendendo e vende muito
foi um negócio que durou cerca de três
meses quando chegou em terceiro mesmo já
tinha vendido para todo mundo que eu
conhecia não tinha mais
ali o que vender pra eles mas aí eu
pensei o que eles precisam eu não tenho
a oferecer
eu conheci o mercado chinesa começar a
importar coisas em sites chineses para
poder vir para o brasil
a última alta lucratividade comecei de
um deles foi outro negócio que não durou
muito tempo foram cerca de dois meses
mas foi bem legal porque com tudo isso
que eu fiz aquele planejamento que eu
fiz de dois anos
os foi encurtado em seis meses no dia 3
de agosto de 2015
eu pisava o meu pé pela primeira vez em
um país europeu primeira vez fora do
brasil
minha segunda viagem de avião eu estava
em outro solo num mas é necessário ter
coragem para se abrir para o novo
às vezes a gente fica com medo de agir
porque não sabe o que vai acontecer eu
também não sabia o que ia acontecer
eu mal falava o idioma achava que sabia
só sabia falar mas denis gabriel era o
que eu sabia inglês
eu cheguei na imigração ea primeira
coisa que eu falei foi dos poucos que eu
não falo inglês mas documentos e
entreguei os documentos para eles foi
bem dessa forma
entreguei e me liberaram eu tava lá em
solo estrangeiro um menino onde ninguém
acreditava que era possível mas a
questão não era o que as pessoas
acreditavam
era o que eu acreditava que era possível
realizar a minha vida e com isso eu
cheguei naquele país com a intenção de
estudar um segundo idioma inglês
matriculei escola de inglês e começou a
minha jornada de aprendizado bem no
início das aulas
eu passei por entrevista para saber qual
é o meu livro no idioma para colocar no
meu turma e eles eu conversando com o
entrevistador ele falou gabriel
você só tem 18 anos você quer trabalhar
foi claro porque trabalhava em um país
acessível que eu possa trabalhar estudar
gabriel é difícil você não tem histórico
você não sabe fazer nada
eu comprei aquela verdade que é
impossível irmão trabalho até que eu
conheci o jonny um grande amigo que se
tornou o irmão em três dias procurando
trabalho a gente conseguiu emprego
conseguiu emprego como que importa
trabalhei bastante lutei fiz acontecer
só que esse trabalho esse cargo só durou
três meses
porque eu me destaquei tanto tempo
daquele restaurante que me promoveram e
aí minha vida mudou eu tive uma melhor
qualidade de vida naquele país chegam
novos aprendizados tive um cargo de
confiança dentro daquele local e as
coisas melhoraram para mim só que para
tudo isso acontecer eu precisei ter
confiança confiança em mim
a criança que era possível acontecer vou
compartilhar com vocês
a história de alguns lugares por onde eu
passei eu passei por muitos lugares
entre a europa ea áfrica
foi uma viagem muito linda só que eu vou
compartilhar não os lugares mais bonitos
os cartões postais mas sim os lugares
que me transformaram como ser humano o
que fizer meu coração pulsar mais forte
que me trouxeram os maiores aprendizados
aqui eu tenho kotor montenegro eu sou o
cara em cima aparecido sempre assim
ali em cima correndo risco de cair
desempenhasse desse castelo diz forte
que a gente estava lá só que eu confiei
eu confiei em mim quando eu fiz essa
viagem estava no país desconhecido e
nunca nunca tinha ouvido falar só quando
estava em um grupo em uma rede social eu
ia falar vai ter uma viagem pra botar um
lugar eu falei eu vou todo dentro
confiei e às vezes a gente precisa
confiar nas pessoas a acreditar no ser
humano é apenas grécia eu tive um outro
aprendizado eu aprendi a contribuir
o poder da contribuição toda todo lugar
turístico tem dois lados
não é só o que a gente vê na televisão
aquela coisa linda que os pontos
turísticos isso é lindo mas tem a vida
real tem a vida real de quem trabalha
naquele lugar é a vida real tem os seus
problemas
eu conhecia os dois lados neste momento
ocasiona ocasional
eu estava andando eu saí os pontos
turísticos visitei tudo estava andando
procurando a lavanderia eo google maps
me levou para um lugar onde eu não
imaginava que haveria na europa na
grécia nunca tinha visto e uma pobreza
de perto lá vendo aquilo eu comecei a
andar e pensar meu deus o que é isso que
está aqui como eu posso contribuir com
esse povo
eu não tinha resposta
quando deu à noite antes de dormir eu
comecei a refletir o meu país passa a
proibir passa por isso eu posso
contribuir lá e esse desejo de
contribuir
essa paixão pelo ser humano começou aí
editar um outro a ter empatia
um outro ponto que trouxe muito é um
cartão postal mas que foi muito
importante
roma itália o poder do networking o
poder de se conectar com pessoas
foi maravilhoso eu cheguei em roma à
noite nunca tinha ido lá e vendo ali eu
tinha reservado um hotel
chegando lá e falaram aqui não tem mais
lugar para você ficar você chegou muito
tarde e isso cancela e sua reserva foi
cancelada por lei como assim cancelada
não tem como eu comprei um site seguro
não gabriel foi cancelada
eu tinha que me virar não foquei naquele
problema mas sim a solução onde eu ia
dormir eu não tinha condição de poder
pagar um outro hotel não conhecia a
cidade nem sabia onde eu estava e eu
lembrei que eu confiei em 39 brasileiros
quando fiz uma viagem e tinha um deles
que morava em roma entrou em contato com
ele e ele recebeu na casa dele é o poder
do networking no marrocos eu aprendi a
dar valor a valorizar quem eu sou a
valorizar a família que eu tenho a
valorizar a casa a cama o travesseiro e
as pessoas que estão ao meu redor me
porque houve a pobreza mais perto ainda
fiquei sete dias no marrocos onde eu
tive a experiência de domingo no deserto
uma viagem incrível foi maravilhoso mas
o mais importante foi um aprendizado
eu aprendi a dar valor de verdade a dar
valor não só nas coisas que são que bom
acabar mas sim nas pessoas que estão em
volta de mim
e foram muitas experiências por vários
lugares que eu passei
e na viagem da vida a gente tem que
aprender a empreender é necessário ter
planejamento para criar um futuro
incrível é necessário que vocês confiem
nas pessoas e confia ainda mais dentro
então sei é necessário que você
contribua
é necessário que você tenha networking é
necessário
o que você ter valor a tudo que acontece
na sua vida porque mesmo que a gente
passa por problemas diariamente são
aprendizados que vão sempre nos tornar
mais fortes em um outro momento da nossa
vida
eu com 22 anos já conheceu em 24 países
e todo todos os locais por onde eu
passei eu tive diversos aprendizados e a
pergunta é essa viagem da minha vida
mas qual que a viagem da sua vida porque
cada um tem a sua jornada tem a sua
história tem a sua família têm os seus
desejos têm o seu sonho o que faz seu
coração pulsar mais forte é contribuir a
estar com a família faça porque nesse
mundo infelizmente a gente tem um prazo
a gente tem um tempo não é eterno
com a viagem da sua vida obrigado